It always kind of throws me for a loop
that this movie starts in Chinatown,
because it’s the one part of the film that
doesn’t look… I don’t know… Christmasy?
The portrayal of Asain-American relations in
Gremlins is actually the key to understanding
the main message of this film, but I’ll
get into that later on in the video. First,
I want to translate these Chinese characters
and see if there’s anything interesting written
here. For the majority of the opening, there is
not, but the store that Mr. Peltzer goes into
where he eventually buys the Mogwai  is called “Magic”,
and as he goes down the stairs, the characters
on the walls mean “God” and “Strange”.
The word Mogwai also means evil spirit, so
if you’re fluent in Cantonese, you already
knew that this shop is no ordinary shop, and Billy
Peltzer’s new pet is no ordinary little creature.
- [Mr. Peltzer] Look, I've gotta have him. It’s a present for my son for Christmas.
- What are you talking about. Your son already has
an adorable dog? But like this store in Chinatown,
the movie itself is filled with many mysterious
secrets. If you want to learn why all of Mr.
Peltzer’s wacky inventions are meaningful,
who this guy in the giant portrait is,
or the true motivation of this drunk guy’s rants,
then stick around to the end of this video.
(metal music)
It’s that time of year again. December
25th. This Jew is going to the movies.
But first I’m gonna talk about a movie.
And that movie is. Called. Final Fantasy
Advent Children. Just kidding. Though
I do like that movie though. It’s pretty cool.
My name is CZsWorld and today, we’re doing
Gremlins. Gremlins was directed by Joe Dante
and released in summer 1984, you already know what
Gremlins is. Let’s get into the Things You Missed.
(knives slashing)
(Christmas music)
We are first introduced to the setting of
Gremlins through this billboard that says
Rockin’ Ricky Rialto Whips Out the Oldies, and
it’s obviously a parody of Indiana Jones. This
is one of many examples of references to
Stephen Spielberg, who directed Indiana
Jones and was the executive producer on
Gremlins. As we’re going through the town,
the movie theater marquee has two titles, A Boy’s
Life and Watch the Skies. A Boy’s Life was at one
time a working title for Stephen Spielberg’s
E.T. The Extra-Terrestrial and Watch the Skies
was at one point a working title for Stephen
Spielberg’s Close Encounters of the Third Kind.
We also see one of the Gremlins utter the line
“phone home ca-ca” before cutting
the phone lines in Billy’s house...
- Phone home ca-ca!
- Which is a reference to the
most famous line from ET.
- ET phone home!
- We also see an ET toy in the department
store where the finale takes place.
In Billy’s room there’s a
poster for Twilight Zone:
The Movie, which was a sci-fi horror
anthology film based on The Twilight
Zone TV show that featured segments from
both Joe Dante and Stephen Spielberg.
Billy’s father is an inventor.
- Now let’s say you’re late for the
big meeting. It’s really important.
You’re on your way in, you reach
up. *gasp* You forgot to shave.
- Uhh… I’ll ignore that.
But later in the movie, on Christmas eve,
Mr. Peltzer uses the phone booth at an
invention convention, and Steven Spielberg can
be seen crossing frame with a broken
foot in some kind of powered wheelchair.
Those are all the Stephen King...
*BEEP*
Those are all the Spielberg easter eggs
I noticed. There are probably others,
so let me know in the comments.
It is Christmas season in the town
of Kingston Falls. As we see when
this kid smashes a snowball on this girl’s head.
Holy sh*t that was brutal.
Kingston Falls is definitely an homage to
Bedford Falls from the classic Christmas
flick It’s a Wonderful Life. We actually see Mrs.
Peltzer watching that movie when Billy comes home,
and the part we see is George Bailey
running by the movie theater marquee,
much like what we just saw
Billy doing in Gremlins.
There are a ton of other similarities. Both main
characters work at a bank. Both have
human antagonists who are money-hungry
holiday grouches who control the town
through their real estate practices.
- [Kate] We’re trying to have Dorry’s
Pub declared a landmark. Mrs.
Deagle’s trying to take his lease away.
- At one point we see one of the
financially insolvent citizens
bargaining with the guy that runs the bank,
another parallel to It’s A Wonderful Life.
And just the look and feel of these two
towns are very similar in a way that I
can’t really put into words.
Also, in Mrs. Deagle’s house,
there's this huge portrait by the stairs of Edward Arnold,
who was known for working with Frank Capra, the director of It's A Wonderful Life.
Edward was at one point considered for playing the role of Potter.
What makes Gremlins so cool though, is that it’s
not just a Christmas movie, it’s not just a horror
movie, but it’s also got elements of science
fiction, some of which you may have noticed.
Everyone knows there are three rules when
it comes to the Mogwai: no bright lights,
don’t get them wet and don’t feed them after
midnight… it’s never really explained what
time it’s OK to feed them again, or if they
follow Daylight Savings time, but whatever.
When you feed them too late they begin their
metamorphosis into Gremlins. It starts when
they go into their cocoons, which are awfully
reminiscent of the eggs in the Alien movies.
In the spot where the cocoons form, there’s
an issue of the famous horror movie magazine,
Fangoria, on the ground, so we know that
this is where the horror is about to begin.
The movie is literally filled
with sci-fi horror references.
The first example is way back at the beginning
of the movie, while Billy is rushing to work.
- [Billy] Hey Dr. Moreau.
- [Dr. Moreau] Morning Billy!
- We later see Dr. Moreau’s
office, he is a veterinarian,
which is really funny because this is
a reference to HG Wells’s 1896 novel:
The Island of Dr. Moreau, which is a story about
a mad scientist who creates human-animal hybrids.
There is a moment when Billy’s Mom is fighting
off Gremlins and she realizes something is moving
in one of the Christmas stockings. She cuts
it open to reveal it was only this robot toy.
I don’t really know what this is doing here.
I mean their only son is at least of out high
school now. Like he has a job at the bank,
I don’t really know who this toy is for.
Remember that convention scene where we
spotted Stephen Spielberg? Well there are
a couple more details to talk about in
that shot. Actually, quite a few more,
including another cameo that may surprise you.
(ambient music)
Please direct your attention to the man
on the right. This is Jerry Goldsmith,
the composer of the score of Gremlins, but what I really
want to point out is this guy, Robby the Robot.
Robby initially comes from the 1956 sci-fi
classic Forbidden Planet. In the background
there’s another HG Wells reference. We can
see the time machine from his 1895 novel:
The Time Machine. The look of the machine
is based on the 1960 movie adaptation. To
be totally honest, I only know what this
looks like because of that one episode of
Futurama with the Forwards Time Machine,
whose design is based off the 1960 movie.
When we cut away to a different scene,
and then come back to the convention,
the time machine is now gone, with
only a puff of smoke left in its wake
so I guess it’s operational.
That’s a fun background detail.
Other sci-fi references include a poster for
the dystopian movie The Road Warrior next to
Billy’s TV, maybe a clue that Gizmo would
be getting behind the wheel before long.
Then there are a bunch of nods to 1950s sci-fi
comics and movies, and I think there may be a
reason that they focus on this era so much. We
see comics like Horrific and House of Terror,
the latter of which requires 3D glasses
which were popular during that time
period. Billy watches the movie Invasion
of the Body Snatchers from 1956, another
film that features alien pods similar to the
cocoons in which the Mogwai become Gremlins.
After Pete calls into Rockin Ricky’s radio
show to report the outbreak of Gremlins,
Ricky broadcasts his frustrations with
all the calls from Kingston Falls.
- Rockin Ricky’s getting fed up with all
this Orson Welles crap, so cool it will ya?
- He’s referring to the famous radio production
of War of the Worlds that was put on by Orson
Welles in 1938. This production was so believable
that people that radio listeners actually thought
there was an alien invasion going on. War of
the Worlds was turned into a movie in 1953.
So what is the deal with all of these
1950s and 60s science fiction references?
There are a lot of them. This, I think, plays
into the overall meaning of the movie Gremlins.
The period of time following the 1945 test
detonation of the first nuclear weapon,
is referred to as The Atomic Age. This blast did
not only have a lasting effect on the area where
it was detonated in New Mexico, but there
was also a *cultural* residual radiation,
and a new wave of science fiction
properties flooded the zeitgeist,
most notably Godzilla, but also the other
titles I’ve pointed out in this video.
If you need more proof that Joe Dante was
specifically referencing the Atomic Era,
I noticed a lot. Billy has a poster
for Agars Atomic Pest Control in his
room. I don’t know exactly what that
is, but it seems like in the movie,
the Gremlins are considered the metaphorical
“Atomic Pests”. We even see Mrs. Peltzer
using flea and tick killer spray to
exterminate some of the Gremlins later on.
The nuclear bomb that United States set off to
begin the Atomic Age was named The Gadget. A slang
term for a gadget, is a gizmo -- which happens
to be the name of our poster boy for this movie.
Also, Mr. Peltzer is an inventor who makes all
kinds of wacky gadgets -- we’ll get into that.
The second rule is to never get the
Mogwai wet. When exposed to water,
they multiply, and the same rule applies
after they’ve metamorphosed into Gremlins.
We see the leader of the Gremlins, Stripe,
jump into a swimming pool at the YMCA,
and this causes some kind of reaction,
causing the water to bubble and turn green,
giving it the appearance of radioactive
material, also known as atomic waste.
The Gremlins take over Dorry’s Pub and
get a little wild and make a huge mess
of the place. When the Dorry’s logo gets
knocked over it looks like a radiation
hazard symbol. I know people are going to
say I’m just looking too much into this,
but we do see this a couple
times in different places.
Then there’s the first rule of the Mogwai
-- they hate bright lights. On more than
one occasion we see the Gremlins’ biggest
weakness is a bright flash -- maybe like
the bright flash that occurs
when an atomic bomb goes off.
(EXPLOSION MEME)
There’s even a part where Mrs. Peltzer
puts one of the Gremlins in the microwave,
and starts it. A microwave transfers heat using
electromagnetic radiation. A much larger scale
example of something that uses radiation
to transfer energy is an atomic bomb,
the thing that The United States
dropped on Japan during World War
II. Like Hiroshima and Nagasaki, this
gremlin explodes.
(grunts and flying guts)
*ding*
Food’s ready!
If you’re familiar at all with 20th Century
History, you probably know why these nuclear
weapons were developed, it was because
of growing international tensions in
World War II. And that brings me back to the
original lore of what a Gremlin actually is.
A Gremlin is an imaginary mischievous sprite
regarded as responsible for an unexplained
problem or fault, especially a mechanical or
electronic one. The term originated as slang
in the Royal Air Force to denote a mischievous
creature that sabotaged World War II aircrafts.
Dante even kind of confirms that the Gremlins in
his movie are in fact an allegory for World War
II Gremlins by including a moment in the pub
scene where one of the Gremlins shoots a gun
at Kate and misses, instead hitting this photo
of what appears to be a World War II aircraft.
Throughout the movie, it is not just war
machines that get taken over by Gremlins. It’s
all machinery. The first example is Billy’s car,
which won’t start when he needs to get to work.
- [Mr. Futterman] These goddamn foreign cars,
they always freeze up on you.”
- [Zac] Billy’s next door neighbor Mr. Futterman spends
the entire movie on a tirade against foreign
machinery. One evening, he got drunk because he
found foreign machine parts in his snow-plow.
- [Mr. Futterman] How’d you like to bring your plow in for a
tune-up and find it loaded with foreign parts?
- The movie seems to have a theme about fear
of overreliance on foreign made products.
Particularly, products made in Asain countries
like China and Japan. The 1980s, when the movie
takes place, were the years that China really
emerged as a manufacturing powerhouse and more
and more technology and machinery started to
be made there, according to St. Louis Fed.
This led to a fear in the United States that China
would surpass the West’s technological dominance.
- [Mr. Futterman] You gotta watch out for foreigners because
they plant Gremlins in our machinery.
The same Gremlins that brought down our planes
in the big one. That’s right. World War II.
- Interestingly, this isn’t the only time we
hear a character use the phrase: The Big One.
- [Rand] I bet every kid in America would like
one of these. They might even replace the
dog as the family pet. The
Peltzer Pet. This could really be the big one.
- In this instance, the pets serve as a metaphor
for the rise of Chinese tech. The Peltzer family
already has a perfectly good dog, Barney. I’m
not the best at identifying dog breeds, but if
I had to guess there’s some terrier in there and
maybe some golden retriever. And these are both
English breeds. We see Barney get jealous that he
now has competition from this Chinese creature,
and when the Mogwai multiply, they terrorize
him and string him up in Christmas lights.
When Gizmo first joins the family, everyone
loves him, but as he multiplies and takes over,
it becomes a big problem. Mr. Peltzer, an American
inventor, has not mastered his own products yet,
but he’s already trying to figure out how
to make money by selling Chinese Gizmos.
- You do with Mogwai
what your society has done with all of nature’s
gifts. You are not ready.
- The only one who seems to understand the danger
of an economy relying on foreign products,
is Mr. Futterman, the same guy who
has a Richard Nixon campaign poster
hanging in his house a decade after Nixon’s
resignation as President of the United States.
(patriotic music)
- We seek friendly relations with all nations.
Any nation can be our friend. Without being
any other nation’s enemy. I have taken this
action, because of my profound conviction,
that all nations will gain
from a reduction of tensions
and a better relationship between the United
States and the People’s Republic of China.
Richard Nixon’s relations with China are
well recognized as one of the most meaningful
parts of his presidency. Now I’m no more an
expert on politics than I am on dog-breeds,
but from what I understand, Nixon was
instrumental in opening up more trade
between the US and China. In his book,
Seize the Moment, he wrote: “If we want
to have an impact on the changes occurring in
China, we should not pull the plug on trade.”
His goal was for American companies to have a
presence in China, but what actually happened
was American companies began producing
goods in Chinese factories to save money.
But perhaps Mr. Futterman initially supported
Nixon because of his intention to take
advantage of free trade with China,
but now he's grown tired of seeing made
in China all over everything he buys.
- You know they’re still shipping them
over here. They put them in the cars,
they put them in the TVs, they put them in the
stereos and the radios you stick in your ears.
They put them in your watches, they got
little teeny Gremlins for your watches.
- As Billy walks Kate home that evening, she
even hints that the reason for his rage
against foreign products may be related
to the relocation of jobs overseas.
- He’s been like that ever since he lost his
job. He’s like a lot of people around here.
- It seems a lot of citizens are blissfully unaware
of the problem, like the Deputy at the police
station. When Billy comes to warn him that the
Gremlins have taken over, he's playing with this
little cowboy game called The Western Man and he
doesn't believe the story about The Gremlins being
a threat. This could represent the typical
American stereotype, that many Americans
believe they are the center of the world and
aren't concerned with international headlines.
He sees Gizmo get tangled up in an American flag,
and totally doesn't read the situation correctly.
- [Sheriff Frank] Patriotic little fella ain’t he?
Waving a flag and everything.
- I don't know about you, but to me, Gizmo does
NOT look happy holding the American flag.
When given the chance Mogwai gravitate towards
Asian products. Like a Japanese
video game, or motor company.
The Gremlins also mess with electronics throughout
their takeover of the town by cutting phone lines,
manipulating stop lights, messing
with antennae, jacking a snow plow,
screwing with the controls of a chair lift…
(woman screaming)
…cutting a police cruiser’s
brake line, blowing fuses all
over the place and broadcasting to
themselves like it’s YouTube 2006.
Finally, the fate of the Gremlins also
plays into this metaphor. Before the
Mogwai turn into Gremlins and
become the main antagonists,
we’re faced with another antagonist,
the grouchy miser, Mrs. Deagle.
She has something against Billy’s dog and
publicly expresses her desire to put him down.
- I’ll put him in my spin-dryer on high heat!”
- So yeah, she can die. Billy can be seen after that
blowing off some steam by drawing a caricature
of her as a dragon being slain by a sword. This
establishes the idea that dragons represent evil.
But that’s not the first dragon we see. There’s
also one in the shop where Rand first purchases…
- An interesting choice of words.
- …Where he first obtains the Mogwai.
- [Rand]] You got yourself a bad case of
dragonbreath. (gong) Bad breath.
- So that’s a couple examples of dragons being
portrayed negatively. Well, when the Mogwai
turn into Gremlins, which happens if they eat
after midnight, perhaps giving themselves that
“dragonbreath”, they develop scales, and
look very reptilian, much like a dragon.
For those reasons, it’s only appropriate
that Billy fights one of them off using
the sword hanging on the wall by his
front door. It’s just like his drawing.
However, the majority of the Gremlins end up
in the movie theater. With all of the ranting
from Mr. Futterman about Gremlins getting into
the machinery and causing bi-planes to crash
during World War II, it is only fitting that the
Americans get back at them with a big explosion.
(explosion)
If you want to see me cover Gremlins II, let me
know in the comments. This is the last video of
this year, but there are gonna be plenty more next
year. Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring that jolly deathbell
and select all notifications, otherwise you’re
getting coal in your stocking and also you’ll die.
I’ll see you next year. Assuming we both survive.
(Christmas music)